china plant wirklich gigantisch es will
die grösste wettermaschine der welt
bauen
damit soll die austrocknung von tibet
verhindert werden durch den klimawandel
droht die region nämlich zu verstecken
china wird es dort jetzt künstlich
regnen lassen wie sie das machen und was
die folgen sind jetzt den klicks um
science-fiction herzlich willkommen aus
new york
15 grad an den weihnachtstagen und dafür
- gerade an ostern das wetter macht was
es will
aber so ganz machtlos sind wir gar nicht
im gegenteil wir menschen können
tatsächlich das wetter beeinflussen
mit silberjodid dämpfte wolken
beispielsweise die lassen es künstlich
regnen und genau das hat jetzt china im
großen stil vor im ganz großen stil
aber wie funktioniert das meistens
werden dafür motor flüge eingesetzt die
über oder unter den wolken fliegen sie
strahlen eine aceton lösung in die
wolken mit die mit silberjodid versetzt
sind der situation sorgt dafür dass
wasser anziehende salze frei werden und
genau die haben dann riesige wolken
zufolge denn sie verbinden sich mit dem
wasser position vieler kleinerer wurden
soeben einer großen weil diese dann so
schwer ist sinkt sie und löst sich auf
es regnet das silberjodid funktioniert
quasi als kondensationskeime das den
wasserdampf dazu bringt ab zu regnen auf
natürlichen wegen funktioniert das
übrigens ähnlich weil eben nicht
ausgelöst silberjodid sondern
beispielsweise durch pollen ruß oder
staubpartikel anstatt silber juli können
auch trockenes oder flüssiger stickstoff
als regen auslöser fungieren und diese
methode ist tatsächlich weiter
verbreitet als man vielleicht denkt
nicht nur in china und russland wird sie
eingesetzt sondern auch hier bei uns in
deutschland
und das nicht weil man den so
entstehenden regen so schätzt sondern
eher um schlimmeres zu verhindern hage
und schlimme unwetter nämlich die idee
dahinter die wolken werden künstlich
dazu gebracht ab zu regnen bevor sich
etwas schlimmeres zusammenbraut die
bauern bezahlen und organisieren das
dann auf eigene faust in deutschland
geht das bei der wetterbeeinflussung
hauptsächlich darum unwetter zu
vermeiden in anderen ländern wird das
anders gehandhabt hier wird zum
besonderen ereignissen gerne auch mal
sonnenschein künstlich erzeugt
beispielsweise in russland bei der
militärparade zum sieg über
nazi-deutschland im vergangenen jahr die
wettervorhersagen waren miserabel doch
die russische luftwaffe ist bekannt
dafür dass sie wolken impft damit diese
dann schon einige zeit vorher und einige
kilometer vor dem ort des geschehens
abregnen sonne pur war zwar nicht das
ergebnis aber immerhin gab es auch keine
ähnlich 2008 in china bei der eröffnung
der olympischen spiele absolut klares
wetter eigentlich waren schwere unwetter
vorhergesagt aber 1000 raketen
behinderten diese und schossen außerhalb
der stadt in den wolken fragen der nehme
doch was macht das mit der umwelt im
gefahrstoffe informationssystemen der
gesetzlichen unfallversicherung ist sehr
periode mit achtung gekennzeichnet die
freisetzung solle vermieden werden
doch dadurch dass sie nur in sehr
kleinen konzentrationen freigesetzt wird
um regen zu vermeiden halten es viele
expertinnen und experten für umständlich
demnach seien keine negativen folgen für
die umwelt zu erwarten und auch nach der
eu gefahrstoff richtlinie dient als
ungefährlich setzte im regen sei es kaum
nachweisbar weil die verdünnung sehr
stark ist dennoch haben die vereinten
nationen schon sehr früh auf diese
technik reagiert und bereits 1977 wurde
die konvention namens entwarf er in
kämpfe unterzeichnet die beteiligten 77
staaten haben dort beteuert dass sie die
umwelt niemals in einem konflikt gezielt
schädigen werden
die un konvention ist tatsächlich eine
reaktion auf den massenhaften einsatz
der silberjodid methode zur
wetterbeeinflussung in den 50er und 60er
jahren sie untersagt ist das wetter zur
kriegsführung oder anderen militärischen
zwecken zu manipulieren
auch deutschland hat die konvention
unterzeichnet dabei ist die ganze
methoden nicht mehr wissenschaftlich
belegt ja richtig denn tatsächlich gibt
es keinerlei statistische studien die
belegen dass dieser wolken beschuss
wirkt denn kaum etwas ist so komplex wie
das wetter und das klima nicht nur der
wind sondern auch die beschaffenheit der
volkan wolken ändern sich andauernd die
man kann zeigen ob es an der jeweiligen
wolken impfungen lag dass es nicht
geregnet hat vielleicht hätte es ja auch
ohne impfung nicht geregnet allerdings
es gibt auch einige zeichen dafür dass
es wirklich funktioniert dani
expertinnen und experten sind der
meinung dass ein paar flugzeugen mit
silberjodid beginnt im gepäck kaum etwas
gegen die gewaltige energie einer wolke
ausrichten können vor allem sei kaum
möglich
zum richtigen zeitpunkt an genau der
richtigen stelle zu impfen
davon ausgeht dass eine wolke
beispielsweise 500.000 tonnen flüssiges
wasser hält bräuchte man unfassbar viel
energie um diese dicke wolke verdunsten
zu lassen nämlich in etwa die energie
von 14 nagasaki atombomben
ja allerdings es ist ja auch nur das
sind ja nur kondensationskeime also sie
müssen eigentlich nicht die energie
einsetzen sondern einfach nur ein paar
kondensation punkte setzt china setzt
zwar kein atombomben aber immerhin
unfassliche 10.000 öfen sie werden
überall in tibet aufgestellt sie
verdampfen silberjodid so dass es durch
aufwände in die wolken getragen wird
angeblich sollen diese öfen über monate
ohne wartung arbeiten
so soll es dauerhaft zum eintrag von
silberjodid in die wolken über dem bett
kommen und sie sollen dort abregnen ob
das funktioniert ob es wirklich so eine
schlaue idee ist fossile brennstoffe
dazu zu verwenden um die folgen des
klimawandels aufzuhalten
das wird die zukunft zeigt das ist in
jedem fall das erste größere geo
engineering project weltweit wir dürfen
gespannt sein wenn er als erstes neues
zum thema geoengineering zu allen
anderen themen erfahren wollt dann endet
meine telefonnummer hierbei whatsapp
oder wir können dort auch mit den
anderen messengern wie instagram
facebook messenger oder telekom euch
anmelden dann erfahrt ihr von mir vor
allen anderen vom neuesten video täglich
garantiert ihr könnte und direkt über
mich in redaktion von finck so mitmachen
und mitbestimmen was sie über kriegs-
und passiert und zur begrüßung gibt es
noch ein kleines bulli einfach hier
draufklicken natürlich nicht das aber
mit der
genau der glocke vergessen hier geht es
weiter dafür auch draufklicken mit
rettet uns geoengineering ansonsten bis
dann bleibt dran